Today we are learning English with  Vanellope and the
Disney Princesses in Ralph Breaks the Internet.
This scene shows Vanellope, the princess of Sugar Rush's game,
meeting and befriending with the Disney Princesses
while on her adventures traveling the internet. Make sure you
stay until the end so you can watch the scene without subtitles
and take a quiz to test what you've learned. Just like
Diana who says that since finding our channel
she has seen a striking improvement in her
speaking and listening. In fact, she's actually started
speaking more like an American and now most
of her friends are in awe of her.
So, if you want to achieve fast results
be sure to click that subscribe button
and bell down below so
you can keep on learning with us!
Before we continue learning with
this funny movie, I want to invite you to
check out the app that we built for learners just like you.  Have
you ever thought it would be possible to improve your listening
comprehension with real-life conversations, understand 100%
of them, AND never forget the most important vocabulary?
With the RealLife App, you will not only see that all of this
is possible, but you'll also be able to connect to other English
learners from around the world and practice your speaking while
discovering other cultures in fun, dynamic, short conversations.
The best part? It is absolutely free! So download it now
by clicking the link here down in the description
or just search RealLife English in the Apple App Store or
Google Play Store. I look forward to seeing you there!
I hope you enjoyed learning with Vanellope
and the Disney Princesses today.
Don't forget to check out our Disney playlist designed to
help you learn English with your favorite animations!
Also, make sure you follow us on Instagram to be informed
of all the lessons we publish every day. Now, on to the quiz!
Now, if you want to learn some fun
ways to learn new words everyday,
I highly recommend you watch this lesson next.